[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the pleasure doing business with you
Sonny Wow dr. PIM
like like who would have thought that
once again in your hour of need that
that you would turn us you know that
mean hmm
help yourself it was about the fancy
pastry we got to keep the food budget
down well what are we supposed to have
for breakfast the oatmeal packets Oh
meal packets
he's insult why is it insults because it
tastes like Saint you know why it's cuz
it's organic no gimmick it's it's the
most important meal of the day you know
what you can get creative with it great
teeth I'll put a little brown sugar on
it you put some cinnamon put a little
honey you guys guys come on man we got
bigger fish to fry
it's not my desk yeah what why do I have
such a small desk because you weren't
there when we were chosen desk your
snooze you lose I was under house arrest
yeah you know what this isn't even a
desk this is garbage you found this
outside amongst garbage I got it at a
rummage sale so you save money on my
desk sighs hope please we need to focus
all right we got to find that lab
already geez change of plans
[Music]
I want that lab boys whatever it takes
[Music]
oh that on the courage it's filthy
they have bigger problems
wasp is a legacy character she's right
there on the cover of Avengers number
one finally every single character from
that first issue of Avengers is here on
the big screen we saw the original wasp
but Janet Van Dyne in a brief flashback
in the first movie and at the end of the
movie we finally saw a new suit and Hank
Pym realizing of course this suit
belongs to his daughter hope it's about
damn time but now in ant-man and wasp
we see her in all her glory watch this
she gets to wear this suit that she's
been coveting her whole life she so
desperately wanted to follow in the
footsteps of her parents who had been
incredible superheroes in their day and
so she's finally doing that oh as this
incredible capability and incredible
drive as a fighter as a scientist to be
this hero she's the toughest one in the
movie she lives to be wasp she lives to
be this superhero man so follow my Reed
this film is primarily a fun clever
emotional story of family because of the
quantum realm is where hopes mother
Janet Van Dyne the original wasp had
been lost presumably forever I was in
the quantum realm and I think I saw it
Janet now the mission becomes can they
go down there and bring it back her mom
I'm not giving up this technology he
gets into the wrong hands it's just
chaos and the stakes are so high we
don't have much time
a man wasp also connects directly to
Avengers for these characters are going
to be very important going forward
teaming up
rated pg-13 and man in the wasp teaming
up this film hope possesses some very
impressive skills
she seems more intense I was so excited
to have the chance to go back to this
character one word that would define the
wasp is kinetic I'm constantly in motion
and there is barely room to breathe I
[Music]
had moments where I think wall how did I
get here tell me you are filming this is
bananas I dare you to blink
[Music]
I just have one question
when cap needed help if I'd asked you
would you have come I guess we'll never
know but if you had you'd have never
been caught
I do some dumb things and the people I
love the most they pay the price thanks
to you we had to run
we're still running let's go
[Music]
maybe you just need someone watching
your back
like a partner
hold on you gave her wings and blasters
so I take it you didn't have that tech
available for me no I did
we unleashed something powerful we call
her the ghost she could destroy the
world I'd love to help you I'm under
house arrest we'll have you home by
lunch I'm gonna come with you guys
[Music]
hang on
pretty job back there thankfully gonna
say the same thing to me good job thank
you
so how long have you been a man again no
uh I just sort of happened like it's
like bad guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch your
back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be gold so
like walks through walls and stuff
slowly Tech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house
happy because we robbed you do you
remember that's us
feeling chef's we've got is the deal
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet
you've 65 feet 65 if you two are
finished comparing sizes 65 the war has
begun and one question remains where is
man
on July 6 two years under house arrest
you haven't had any contact with Hank
for hope have you hmm
real hero's awesome
if only cap could see you now that man
and the wasp get tickets now
[Music]